اعرب المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
دانييل هجاري عن اسفه الشديد لاغتيال
الزميله شيرين ابو عقله وجاء ذلك خلال
مقابله له مع شبكه
اقول هنا اننا نشعر بالاسف لمقتل الرحله
شيرين ابو عاقله كانت صحفيه مرموقه جدا
نحن في اسرائيل لدينا ديمقراطيه وفي
الديمقراطيه نقدر جدا الاعلام والصحافه
الحره نريد ان يشعر الصحفيون بالامان في
اسرائيل خاصه في زمن الحرب وحتى لو
انتقدونا فنحن نريدهم ان يشعروا بالامان
الامر كله يتعلق بالديمقراطيه ونحن
الديمقراطيه ليبراليه
المساءله بشان اغتيال زميله شيرين ابو
عقله اضافنا الخارجيه الامريكيه دانت قتل
شيرين قبل عام كما تدين ذلك اليوم ايضا
وفق تعبيره
لقد شجبنا مقتل شيرين قبل عام وندينه
اليوم ايضا ونواصل السعي وراء المساءله
للضمان اتخاذ خطوات لمنع وقوع ماس مماثله
في المستقبل نؤكد على اهميه المسائله بشان
مقتل شيرين لكن تنبغي الاشاره هنا الى ان
الخلاصات التي توصل اليها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وكذلك تلك التي ناقشناها الصيف
الماضي مع منسق الامن الامريكي تؤشر حتى
الان الى ان هذا الحادث الماساوي للغايه
ليس متعمدا